okay now for our final speaker
of the day of this program he has spoken
for the college several times over the
years his first appearance for the
college was way back
in 1991 at a national leadership seminar
like this one
and we are delighted he could be with us
again
uh he's the national affairs columnist
for national review and a contributor
to fox news he writes and speaks
regularly on the connections between
american politics economics
and legal issues he previously served as
a columnist and editorial board member
at the wall street journal for 27 years
early in his career he worked as a
research analyst for the california
legislature in sacramento
and later made the move into journalism
as a reporter for the syndicated
columnists roland evans
and robert novak he's a frequent guest
on radio and television
and the recipient of numerous awards
from
organizations such as the institute for
justice and the fund for american
studies
he's the co-author of two books obama's
enforcer eric holder's justice
department
and also who's counting how fraudsters
and bureaucrats put your vote at risk
he's also the author of the book
stealing elections how voter fraud
threatens our democracy
today he'll be talking about election
integrity please welcome john fund
so believe it or not
i will be ending with an optimistic
message
not only do i believe it but you deserve
it
after what you've heard
i have been interested in election
integrity since
i was in college and as part of a term
paper i observed a recount process
in california my home state and i
observed with my own eyes voter fraud
occurring
and people always ask well why didn't
you report it to the authorities
and i said well it was the authorities
who were doing it
ever since then i have sought out
examples
of how our democracy is in peril my
favorite conversation ever was with
james lasky the city clerk of chicago
at the time he was about to leave
office because he had just been
convicted of
embezzlement fraud and bribery and he
was very candid because he had found god
and he said i feel a need to speak out
and he said
you know when i first got into chicago
politics
i was told about the 1960 election and
then i realized boy have they perfected
it since then
he said just remember as he left me
no representation without respiration
one of the things i've learned from
hillsdale over the years since i first
got in primus when i was 15 years old
is the power of narrative
and hillsdale at a much higher level of
scholarship
in its undergraduate and graduate
programs is about
the narrative of america the story of
america
and at a very high powered level but you
know
in life we learn outside our own
personal experience from stories
from narratives the biggest change that
has happened in the media since i
started
40 years ago is
they have decided to seize control of
one narrative
and push it to the exclusion of all
other narratives
and that's what voter fraud's narrative
is all about
how many times have you heard there is
no voter fraud as paterson new jersey
has to call a new election as they find
1700
ballots in the back room in sussex
county new jersey
as two county commissioners in greg
county texas
are just indicted i mean over and over
again
these stories flip by but there is no
voter fraud
there is only voter suppression by evil
racist conservatives
well i'm going to give you a different
narrative
it has one advantage it's true
let's queue up a videotape this is only
three minutes of a 16 minute
segment on what happened in minneapolis
that james o'keefe and project veritas
has uncovered
james was on hannity last night you
might have seen it but this three
minutes will give you a flavor
of what really happens that you aren't
told about by the mainstream media
james o'keefe here in downtown
minneapolis at the scene of the
crime the person you're about to meet
leibon muhammad aka
king libon1 boasts about the hundreds of
absentee ballots in his car
numbers don't lie numbers don't like
there was video you can see the video
there was a video out and about
that he has the ballots in his car right
and talking about
the only way you can win is with money i
was looking at them and they were not
filled
they were blank who is the one filling
out the absentee ballots
people who work with like omar
where do they pay the money the the
minute we sign the thing
the election that's what you can pay
money is everything
money is the key in this world if you
ain't got money you shrimp
and they took every just take ballot
every ballot
knock on the door and say your ballots
come give it to me give it to me they
don't even pay them for it they just
take it no
and the ones that didn't vote on balance
the young people
and the women and stuff they were paying
cash cash they were getting bags of
money the last one here to drive people
so there's a vested interest but we are
victims of the system
they don't give a [ __ ] about any similar
issues sorry to use myself no no
you're right
two in the morning still hustling
who is the one filling out the absentee
ballots
the people who work
yes
watch the whole video and by the way
james o'keefe has done
at least a dozen of these over the years
and
many of them have had results the
minneapolis police department which
is an open secret they know about this
has finally been forced to investigate
and even some district attorneys might
have to get involved
you might think this is just one city
but minnesota changed the country in
your lives
in 2008 the comedian al franken ran for
senate
the election was very close it took six
months of recounts and court judgments
before franken was declared the winner
by 317 votes
the lawyer pushing that was named mark
elias
he became most infamous because he was
the bag man for hillary clinton and the
dnc
giving the money to fusion gps for the
steele dossier and he lied about it
under oath in a deposition
he is the democratic quarterback behind
160 lawsuits
that are trying to transform our
elections from election day
into an election month before the vote
early voting and mail-in voting and an
election month
after the vote where they go to court
and judge shop to try to have judges
decide how the voters voted rather than
the voters decide how voters voted
that's what we're up against his victory
for
al franken was later proven
to be fraudulent in addition to the
varying standards of absentee ballots
they were counted by one standard in
blue counties and another standard in
red counties
in addition to all of the other
shenanigans
it was discovered by a group called
minnesota majority that 1200 felons who
had not completed their probation or
parole
and were not eligible to vote had voted
in that election
the fox news affiliate in minneapolis
took a survey of these people their
names were known
ninety percent voted for franken do the
math
ninety percent of twelve hundred is ten
eighty the election margin was three
317.
now of course it's very difficult to go
after these people because effectively
what you have to do
to take it to a jury is overwhelming
proof
you basically have to have people admit
that they did it and they knew it was
wrong when they did it
well lo and behold some felons aren't
smart
and 287 felons were convicted of this
crime
after the election after franken was
seated
they actually went in and said to the
prosecutors
not only did i do it i knew i was doing
wrong
the margin was 317. you do the math we
almost have as many people convicted of
this crime as the margin
franken became the 60th vote to break
filibusters in the u.s senate in 2009
obamacare would not have passed if the
democrats hadn't broken the filibuster
60 40.
it is generally considered
accurate that we would not have
obamacare in our
current form if al franken hadn't been
there to cast the 60th vote
changed history we may be about to
change history again
in not a good way if we allow the same
tactics and the same depredations to
occur in this election
now first piece of good news
tulsi gabbard is the first simone
american to serve in congress she ran
for president of the democratic
primaries
she's the one who took a two by four to
kamala harris in the debates
she has just become the lead co-sponsor
of a bill
to ban the ballot harvesting you just
saw up there
there's a video which you can find in
which she says
project veritas offers further evidence
of the need to ban ballot harvesting it
is not a partisan issue
we need to ban this practice at least by
not having any federal money
to finance election improvements to go
to any state that allows this procedure
now here's the sad thing i was talking
about narrative
and all that i've learned from hillsdale
and dr arn
about the importance of narrative
we used to have a different narrative on
voter fraud in the media
journalists used to win pulitzer prizes
for uncovering voter fraud in miami and
cleveland
it was bipartisan chris dodd the
democratic senator who
was the lead sponsor of the help america
vote act after the florida
bushfigure contest actually said the
purpose of this bill is to make it easy
to vote and hard to cheat we are
americans we can do both
in 2005 a presidential commission was
formed
the chairs were former president jimmy
carter and former secretary of state
james baker
bipartisan 21 members 10 democrats 10
republicans
one independent by 18 to 3
they voted that america should have a
nationwide voter id requirement by 18 to
3.
and in fact here is what the commission
said
voter fraud is most frequently found
in absentee and mail-in balloting these
ballots which are
filled out in the absence of government
supervision
are the easiest way to subvert our
democracy
that was the presidential commission
headed by jimmy carter
in the q a i can tell you a marvelous
story that carter himself told me i
testified before that commission
marvelous story of why
he dissents from the current democratic
orthodoxy that there is no voter fraud
his first election was stolen from him
and if it hadn't been for a brave
federal judge who rescinded the election
and called for a new one
his blood career would have been over
before it began
the new york times in 2012
did a comprehensive study in which they
concluded
that voter fraud in absentee and mail-in
balloting
was a nationwide epidemic
here's the actual quote
while fraud in voting by mail
is not as common as innocent errors it
is vastly more prevalent than an
in-person voting fraud that has
attracted more attention
there is a bipartisan consensus in this
country that voting by mail
whichever its impact is more easily a
blues than any other form of voting
that was october 2012
down the memory hole
every democrat now is forced to submit
to the orthodoxy along with their media
collaborators
that there is no voter fraud
well how bad is it getting
a secretary of state was on a panel with
me a couple of years ago
and i challenged her on this after the
panel i said
how in the world you know what's
happening two state legislators in your
state have just been convicted of voter
fraud
how can you go out on that panel and say
there's no voter fraud you just had two
state legislators convicted of it
and she looked at me and she said words
that took a chill up and down my spine
she said if you can't win a majority in
this country
you have to create a new majority and i
said what does the word create mean and
she says it can mean whatever you want
it to
mean that's what we're having
now many people i can assure you this is
not a grand conspiracy
it only happens when they know the
election is close
they can assemble the resources in
advance the walking around money the
cash that you heard referenced up there
and they can focus attention on it and
make sure the media stays asleep
it's not everywhere and it doesn't
happen every election
it's targeted when it counts and believe
me it counts
next month in november
now
where do we go from here
well first of all what we have to
understand
is a lot of people
doing this are not part of some grant's
conspiracy
it's done at the very local level i can
assure you
that if you applied truth serum to every
democratic senator and almost every
democratic congressman elon omar
accepted
and you provided truth serum they would
say they don't know anything about voter
fraud in their state or district
it's designed so they don't know they
don't ask
and they're never told it's a great
conspiracy of silence
that's the biggest conspiracy out there
not the others many of them are
poppycock
and frankly unfortunately president
trump who at least has given rise to
this issue he sometimes exaggerates and
invents things that
aren't always the case he's been helpful
in some ways and not helpful in others
with his tweets
but the conspiracy of silence is real
but sometimes people will step forward
artur davis an african-american
congressman from alabama
in 2011 stepped forward he was leaving
office and he wrote a piece
for the wall street journal that i
published in which he said you want to
talk about voter fraud
every election campaign people in my
district come to me and say
how many votes would you like here's
what it will cost you
well his future the democratic party
ended at that point
several years later he became a
republican he still speaks out on this
issue
but he is persona non grata in the media
the fact that you've never heard of him
is what they do to people who speak out
on this issue
now
you say well this is all anecdotal this
is historical
this isn't current except for this
minneapolis thing
here's today's headline today
biden's texas political director accused
of illegal ballot harvesting at texas
supreme court
two undercover agents one a former
houston police detective and one another
former fbi agent
discovered that biden's campaign
director dallas jones in texas
are currently hoarding male and absentee
ballots and ordering operatives
to fill out the ballots to people
illegally including for dead people
homeless people and nursing home
residents
well no they say in the media this is
not happening this is not
proven and besides it's dwarfed by the
voter suppression
give me a break look
let's be very very clear
the democrats are practicing what is
called projection
it's a psychological term which
basically means you project and accuse
others of the behavior you yourself are
guilty of
you do it for two reasons one you
convince yourself you're not really
doing anything wrong
and you probably can pass the truth
serum test and two
if you do know what you're doing is
wrong you attack the other party
and confuse everyone to avoid any
attention to what you're doing
and this belief that there is voter
suppression in this country on a grand
scale
is precisely that it's projection
i'm here to tell you the biggest dirty
little secret about voter fraud
the victims the worst
cases the people most oppressed by this
are minorities
all of these cities you've heard about
bad police
bad roads bad schools
bad infrastructure most of them are run
by machines
run by liberals how do they stay in
power
well there are all kinds of tactics but
if nothing else works
there's voter fraud go where you wish
milwaukee st louis detroit
dallas philadelphia
baltimore if the reformers the people in
the community who haven't moved to the
suburbs
if the reformers many of whom are
minorities get up enough courage and
gumption to run against the machine and
say we can do better
the machine will squash them like a bug
kwame killed patrick the mayor of
detroit
until he had to spend some time in
federal public housing
he ran for re-election a few years ago
he lost the initial primary they had to
go to runoff because no one got 50
percent he was considered
dead politically then at the end
somehow there was this flood of absentee
mail in ballots that pushed him over the
top
i talked to his opponent freeman hendrix
who said we know the fraud exists we
couldn't get anyone in the obama
administration to pay attention
anyone a couple years later the city
clerk
of detroit was removed from office
for mismanagement and fraud she didn't
want to leave
she had to be picked up in her chair and
literally carried out of her office
by the police that really happened
one final anecdote bruce franks 31 years
old
an activist in his community someone who
really was
concerned about genuine police brutality
of which there is some
and we do have to worry about it my
brother was the deputy chief of police
in tucson arizona
believe me my brother says the biggest
single barrier
to enforcement of the law when he was
deputy chief of police
is the police union because it protects
the bad cops
that's the dirty little secret but the
left won't tell you that because they
have to protect all unions
well here's what happened to bruce
franks and st
louis he decided he was going to run
against the political machine
run by the hubbard family in saint louis
and he was going to run against the
matriarch of the machine
old mother hubbard victoria hubbard
he ran against her he knocked on every
door he had a message
we can change things primary august
2016.
he wins at the ballot box but he loses
the absentee vote 80 to 20.
he loses 51.49
but he goes to court some stool pigeons
come forward and say
we participated in massive fraud a
federal judge
bravely says this election is so riddled
with fraud
i'm a nulling it and we're calling a new
election in six weeks
same electorate same district same
candidates
it was in september
now obviously this publicity may have
hurt
old mother hubbard's reputation but it
was still a machine and she still was a
long-term
state legislator she got 29 percent of
the vote
and guess who won the absentees bruce
frank's not her
funny how that works bruce franks told
me
the biggest obstacle in saint louis to
changing the
city is the machine will steal the votes
that's necessary
to elect their people and they have the
gall
to say we're suppressing votes
they're stealing votes we have two
civil rights in this country the first
we fought a great civil rights struggle
in the 60s over
it was marvelous we need to preserve and
protect those gains
no poll taxes no literacy tests no
blocking people from voting
no intimidation that is essential to
american democracy
it's in the best spirit of lincoln and
what we fought for
freedom for everyone
but everyone has a second civil right
not just the right to be prevented not
to be prevented from voting
but the right to not have your ballot
cancelled out
invalidated by someone who's voting who
shouldn't be voting
if you vote and your vote is canceled
out by someone who's dead
someone who's moved out of state someone
who doesn't exist someone whose address
is a parking lot
someone who's a non-citizen if you vote
and your vote is canceled out you have
lost your right to vote as much as if
someone stood in a polly house store and
said you can't come in here
and they say we shouldn't have voter id
look at this this isn't
a fire hose this isn't a billy club
this isn't a voter suppression device
this is an id
you need it in america to join the
mainstream of american life
the story you have never been told is
the following
in early 2017
jimmy carter bill clinton
martin luther king iii andrew young
came together at a conference and said
i'm sorry 2016 when obama was still
president
and said you know we're going to break
this impasse on voting
let's have a compromise instead of
fighting voter id if anybody doesn't
have an id let's go get them one
andy young told me it's a freedom card
you can't travel you can't get a loan
you can't get benefits you can't get
medicare
you can't cash a check without one of
these so let's get it to people
and if there's people who believe that
some states are
too backward to really pursue this
let's take the social security card we
all have and let people put a photograph
on it
and if they can't get a state id they
can show a social security card with a
photo on it
so they had a meeting with eric holder
and they had a meeting with obama's
political advisors
obama was too smart to see them and they
said let's do this
bipartisan we have the votes
well the obama administration had to
consult their leading ambassador to the
minority community and his name was al
sharpton
and he nixed it and they have the gall
to say there's voter suppression we had
a solution
right here and they said
no we prefer people don't have to show
id
we have other plans for them
so i promised you to end in an
optimistic message and i know you have a
lot of questions
so here's the optimistic part
vote fraud is a lot like shoplifting
talk to anyone in the retail industry
and they'll tell you if you do three
things
three things put up a camera in your
store
even if no one watches it have a
security guard even if he's half asleep
and put up a sign that says shoplifters
will be prosecuted
you do those three things and you cut
shoplifting 35-40 percent
because there are lots of people in this
country
whether they litter or whether they do
graffiti or whether it's any kind of
petty crime
or even big crime they'll only do it
if there's no risk and they know no one
is watching
same thing with shoplifting same thing
with voter fraud
just that's why they have to say there
is no voter fraud
because if they ever admitted there was
any there'd have to be something to be
done about it and that
something would cause some people who
don't want to take any risk
not to cooperate with them if even
there's just a little risk
a lot of people won't take the cash a
lot of people won't go out on the
streets
a lot of people won't give cigarettes to
the homeless to go home vote
so a little bit of effort in the next
35 days can pay great dividends
there are 97 u.s attorneys in this
country
all of them appointed by donald trump
many of them on their own and i hope the
justice department gives the marching
orders they're going to be issuing press
releases
and holding press conferences and saying
we will protect the right to vote
we're also going to protect your right
not to have your ballot invalidated by
cheaters
and a lot of these efforts around the
country to change the election rules
to blow away guard rails like signature
requirements
witness requirements postmark
requirements for absentee ballon ballots
are being blocked pennsylvania that case
is going to go to the supreme court
which may have a ninth member deciding
that very quickly
and even if there are only eight members
it may be decided very quickly
so my message to you is
this is the biggest false narrative of
this entire election and that's saying a
lot given russiagate
and all of the other gates out there
this
is brazen and bizarre
and bold all at the same time
but the american people aren't buying it
the washington post conducted a poll in
2016
and i'm closing with this the washington
post conducted a poll
in 2016. 84 percent of republicans
believe that a meaningful amount of
voter fraud occurred in u.s elections
75 percent of independents and 52
percent of democrats
and do you know that minorities actually
believe that voter fraud is a
more pressing important problem in this
country than caucasians do
and the reason is so many of them
actually know what's happening
in the cities in the back woods and the
counties
now here's another poll that'll also
give you some optimism mark penn was
bill clinton's pollster
yes yes he's learned the error of his
ways it wasn't hillary's pollster
at least he learned knew where to stop
he conducted the poll that's just out
this morning
the harris harvard poll remember the old
harris poll
they asked the question who do you think
is being given
far too easy time in the media and a far
too hard time in the media
trump 65 percent too hard a time
35 percent no biden
62 percent way too easy at time 38
no no matter how the media tries to
construct only one narrative and ignore
all others no matter how much they try
to avoid the facts that i've laid out to
you
it's not working that well for them
the rise of alternative media and by the
way i consider him primus and it's 5.6
billion subscribers one of the best
forms of alternative media i know
[Applause]
the alternative media gets through to
anyone who actually wants to get the
message now here's where you come in
you have more power than you realize
all of you have lists of friends
neighbors relatives colleagues at work
people you know people who trust you
they're on your email list
they're on your listserv marketing firms
will tell us
on a scale of one to a hundred with 100
being i see a message or i see an
ad and i think it's from
my sainted mother who has my best
interest always at heart
and zero is the snake sleaze ball of the
used car lot
somewhere in between everybody gets a
rating
political ads get about a 20 or 25.
most people don't believe them soap cars
internet services between 35 and 50.
but if someone gets a message from a
friend neighbor colleague or relative
the trust level starts about 65 and goes
up to about 95.
you're in that mix if you send something
to a friend neighbor relative or
colleague at work
so take these stories and i'll be happy
to
send you links my email is
johnfun99 gmail.com but i can email it
to people here
johnfun99 gmail.com
send these links with perhaps some words
of your own
validating them to your friends
neighbors relatives and colleagues at
work
i kind of the people in this audience
based on what i know about internet
usage and email usage
there's a universe of about twenty five
thousand people
that you and this audience can reach get
the message out
you have 35 days thank you
thank you mr fund